our scripture that I Psalm 18:29
in your strength I can crush an army
with my god I can scale any wall Charles
Spurgeon said by perseverance the snail
reached the Ark you know that is
something we haven't talked about Chris
that the the the guys that and gals that
become millionaires almost none of them
did it quickly mmm there's very few
get-rich-quick stories in these not only
did they they didn't strike gold they
didn't invent a piece of software they
didn't take a company public in most
cases it's slow and steady wins the race
the tortoise versus the hare I don't
know what the percentages are I don't
know that we asked that particular
question right but just a total
observation of how they did it and how
their wealth was built a lot of its 401
K a lot of steady investing into their
retirement a steady reduction of their
mortgage so that they have this nice
home paid off and they have this nice
nest egg that they gradually built no
Dave you're absolutely right building
wealth is this mindset and a process
that does take time I mean as I talked
about on my show all the time your
money's to best friends our time and
compound interest and so these everyday
millionaires followed the plan the
lessons you've been teaching for over 30
years and they were consistent with it
you know they didn't allow us shiny they
knock them off their plan for example
these crypto currencies right Bitcoin I
mean all of that if you look at that the
values of Bitcoin since January is down
by almost 80% a guy treated me this
morning about his dad his dad's brothers
and sisters there's I don't know you
probably don't even remember this but
like 20 years ago there was just crazy
out there
people were buying emus birds because
emu meat was gonna be the next delicacy
was going to be the big thing and it was
like us get-rich-quick craze to buy emus
well his dad said I'm not buying me I
don't know anything about birds the
brother/sister put all their money that
lost all their money went broke and emus
I mean there's always something shine
there's always some dumb but yeah
get-rich-quick thing out there that's
gets hammered with forgotten ugliest
bird yes unbelievable
I'll pakka yeah that was one see ya
around alpacas and Bitcoin I feel like I
should do a blog post emails alpacas in
Bitcoin what are these three have in
common
sad investments you eat one you wear one
and I don't even know one you just won't
just lost money right so hey if you need
some help with your investing and want
to set up a steady plan click smart
investor Dave Ramsey common drop down a
list of the smart Vista pros in your
area you choose which one you want to
sit down and talk to and meet with
someone that has the heart of a teacher
and has a long-term plan they're not
gonna get your rich quick if somebody
starts telling you they're gonna get
your rich quick run as fast as you can
away Andrew and Allison welcome to an
everyday millionaires theme hour here on
the Dave Ramsey show hi baby
what you guys net worth 2.7 awesomeness
very good break that down for me how's
it invested you've got about eight
hundred thousand in a PDF house a
hundred in cash a hundred in bond
retirement investments and the rest but
1.7 in retirement
alright very well done and how old are
you - I'm 42 I'm 45 young millionaires
well done how much of this 2.7 did you
inherit zero okay and what's been your
range of income best but worse you're
the best year household income I think
probably our worst year when we started
out with about 75 and best year was
probably about 600 whoa nice what do you
guys do for a living we're EMU farmers
[Laughter]
tell us the truth what did you do it's
so great what are your degrees I have a
degree in finance and marketing mm-hmm
okay two business degrees or your GPAs
3.8 buzz all right very cool very cool
so how much of this is there because you
borrowed money to make money using other
people's money or leverage non-0 okay
cool what advice do you have to the
younger version of you listening out
there
my advice is basically don't fall into
credit card debt you know there are a
lot of kids a lot of kids in college
right now that are are strapped for cash
for student loans and trying to find a
way to get through it and I think a lot
of them are solving indicated done and I
know I did when I was in that situation
so then that would be my advice mm-hmm I
can it can still be done just marry an
emu farmer so fun tell me the best book
you've read one of you in the last
couple of years nan Ramsey most recently
the book mindset by Carol Dweck is all
about having a growth mindset and this
continues to improve and get better and
it's been great with our kids yeah
several of our people around the company
reading that right now I hadn't read it
yet but I seen it flying around here
very cool highly recommend yeah yeah
really good very good how much TV do you
are watching a week it's usually on in
the bathtub cause we're sitting on the
couch with our laptops but maybe an hour
or two a day yeah very little okay
so you're not big TV people you couldn't
tell us who got the last rose or
anything I love it well congratulations
you two
very well done